hi I'm Eric Voss and spider-man far from
home wasted no time in this post endgame
recovery period to release a new trailer
with Tom Holland actually given us a
spoiler warning for once and revealing
the insane ways the MCU will move on
after endgame multiverse is depressing
Ironman art Nick Fury calling Peter
Parker a [ __ ] it is truly the darkest
timeline and I'm gonna break down this
far from home trailer frame by frame for
all the details that you might have
missed and explaining the secret
conspiracy that this footage could be
hiding spoiler warning for avengers
endgame and in case I predict anything
to accurately for far from home spoiler
warning for that too let's get started
everywhere I go I see his face missin ya
missin too I don't think Tony would have
done what he did if he didn't know that
you were gonna be here after he was gone
okay after Tom Hollands opening spoiler
warning the kid really has come a long
way and taking great spoiler
responsibilities to go with his great
spoiler power this trailer opens on
spider-man in Queens New York wearing
the iron spider suit given him by Tony
Stark an infinity war because as has
been confirmed by the studio and
filmmakers spider-man far from home
takes place shortly after the events of
Avengers in games so this is set in the
Year 2023 after the five-year time jump
after Bruce Banner snapped back all the
dusted and after Tony Stark died by
snapping away baños and his forces now
this kind of presents some timeline
confusion because along with Peter Ned
MJ flash and Betty Brant all looked the
same age when the students in Peters
school should have aged five years
during that time jump period so I guess
we're meant to assume that all of those
particular classmates happen to all get
snapped as well meaning they wouldn't
have aged either yes I suppose it is a
bit of a coincidence that exactly the
memorable faces of Peters academic
decathlon team got affected by this
supposedly randomized cosmic rapture but
all the members of my high school
mathlete team got mono so it's possible
it could even be that this euro trip in
the movie was arranged for return snap
victims to get away since they would now
be in classes with students who were
previously five years younger than them
and it might be kind of weird for flash
to see the little sixth graders used to
pick on having now hit their growth
spurts
these five years and now tower over
Peter sees this Iron Man tribute mural
saying everywhere I go I see his face
behind him the train passes by reminding
me at least of our other beloved
departed figure Stanley whom the
animators of spider-man into the
spider-verse snuck into a number of
passing trains like into the
spider-verse far from home is opening
this world to the Marvel multiverse so I
like to think that Stan could be
circling the city on the Train of this
New York to happy hogan tells a tear
stricken Peter I don't think Tony would
have done what he did if he didn't know
that you were gonna be here after he was
gone Stark's sacrifice and in game was
largely inspired by Peter Parker in
particular early an in-game stark told
cap I lost the kid and it is a photo
with Peter that Spurs Stark to
reconsider the time heist and he makes
sure to give Peter a big bear hug when
he returns calling back his non hug and
homecoming there's not a hug I'm just
grabbing the door for you but within
game Tony finally got there with Peter
and now the main theme for far from home
appears to be the question of who will
carry on Iron Man's legacy Peter Parker
or some other Peter Pretender moving on
you gonna be a next Iron Man now well no
I don't have time I'm too busy doing
your jobs oh I'm kidding I'm kidding
look keep up the good work because I am
going on vacation okay Peter uses the
iron spider armor to take out some thugs
in his fancy restaurant webbing some of
them to the walls and using his suits
extendable arms
they're called Waldo's in the comics to
block a club in a kitchen knife
among these awesome functions are these
web grenades that fire back as
projectiles and explode at people's feet
staring them up into the ceiling now
it's not clear who this gang is but
behind the chandelier the webbed person
wears a flashy leopard print suit with
Pierce heels yes I'm wondering if this
could be an adaptation of the Spidey
villain Kraven the hunter and the cop
that Peter teases has a name badge
Bristow
now Peter Bristow is a character
associated with the New Mutants and the
x-men comics but I'm not sure it's
connected and the game actually featured
a more possible x-men Easter Egg with
Roberto decosta on the memorial aka
sunspot from the X been comic but in
this case not every name is a conspiracy
theory that goes all the way to the top
next clip heads up Nick Fury is calling
you I don't really want to talk to me
why because if you don't talk to him and
I have to talk I don't want to talk
about you sent Nick Fury to voicemail I
gotta go you do not ghost Nick Fury
okay Nick's is a shot from the past
trailer with Peter swinging past Grand
Central Station with it's Avengers
monument on top that was added after the
Battle of New York and behind it is
Avengers tower under renovations maybe
during the five year time period an end
game a new owner would have bought the
space turning this tower into perhaps
the Oscorp building or the Baxter
building of the Fantastic Four Petersons
Nick Fury to voicemail and behind happy
is this old wrestling poster it lists
crusher Hogan which is the name of the
wrestler that Peter Parker faced in the
exhibition match in the comic book
origin and actually beneath crusher
Hogan is the name bone saw McGraw the
name of the wrestler that Macho Man
Randy Savage laid in the Sam Raimi
spider-man exhibition match
spider-man more than any Marvel
character is super connected to his
multiverse counterparts which into the
spider verse nailed so I love that this
live-action version is working in little
knots do both the comics and alternate
film adaptations of this character okay
moving on George what's up we're just
talking about the trim here in st. Marco
Polo's oh I think MJ really likes me
when I first alone you're a very
difficult person to contact spider-man
behind Peter in this art classroom is
more tribute art to Iron Man more
reminders to Peter of his loss and the
legacy that he's feeling pressured to
take on then to Venice where Flash gets
not checked during a selfie video this
takes place in venice's Plaza San Marco
aka st. Mark's Plaza or as it sounds
like flash is about to call it st. Marco
Polo's the crew for this movie filmed
on-location so a lot of these background
extras might have actually been legit
tourists on the day maybe it's just me
but that guy looks a lot like Joe Russo
doesn't he maybe I'm just used to seeing
Joe Russo cameo in every Marvel movie he
directs or maybe just stocky residents
of Venice look a lot like Joe Russo fury
hits Ned with a tranq Dart totally chill
thing for an adult stranger to do to a
child and he tells Peter you're a very
difficult person to contact spider-man
but notice that this line was changed
from the first trailer when fury said so
nice to finally meet you
spider-man that could be because both of
these characters were present at Tony
Stark's funeral and Avengers end game
theory was creeping in the back with
Maria hill so it's possible that Peter
didn't meet them but it's just another
example of how that first trailer was
edited to try to hide avengers endgame
reveals moving on this is mr. bet you
could use someone like you on my world
new world Vic is from Earth just not
ours a snap to our hole in our dimension
your session multiverse we have a job to
do
you're coming with us okay here is where
things get nuts Peter meets Quintin Beck
aka the spider-man villain Mysterio
played by Jake Gyllenhaal Peter's told
that Beck is from an alternate earth in
the multiverse and at the snap tore a
hole in this dimension okay huh so the
existence of the Marvel multiverse isn't
really news Doctor Strange introduced
the idea and Avengers endgame barked out
a version time-travel with all kinds of
alternate universe ramifications so like
now there's a separate branch universe
where Loki is still alive a universe
where Thanos went missing in 2014 and
the guardians of the galaxy an hour came
together in depending on whether you ask
the directors or the screenwriters a
universe where old man cap is trying to
prevent 911 from happening but while the
multiverse does sound like a real thing
now being part of the MCU similar to the
animated multiverse of into the spider
verse there is a good chance that
Quentin Beck is lying Mysterio is known
as a master of illusion deception in
hypnotism actually in the Ultimate
Comics the earth 16:10 Mysterio is
revealed to be an Android remotely
controlled by the earth-616 Mysterio in
order to conquer that version of Earth
so while it appears here that Beck is
working with fury and he'll to fight
these elemental villains attacking
European city it's back could just be
claiming to be a superhero from another
universe when they wouldn't know when
really he's a con man from this universe
a guy who's a wizard of special-effects
creating these hoaxes for himself to
play the hero you'll notice that one of
the technicians here is the actor Newman
a car who's rumored to be playing a
character named Dmitri which someone
speculated it could be the version of
the villain Dmitri Smerdyakov the
chameleon this guy could be in cahoots
with Beck helping create these illusions
it is surprising that Nick Fury would be
fooled by this but he could be under
Mysterio's hypnosis or maybe he is
suspicious and that is why he brought in
spider-man a real superhero to help
investigate if Beck is who he says he is
it's also interesting that fury says the
snap caused the hole in the dimensions
because that makes me wonder which snap
theya knows his first snap at me an
infinity war hulk snapped to bring
everyone back
Tony's snap to kill thanos I suppose
it's true that any of those snaps would
have been universe rupturing of
that could have ripped the fabric of
reality but remember thinness also use
the stones to destroy the stones you've
reduced them to atoms now we don't know
if that was a snap motion per se but the
ancient one did say that the stones were
necessary to maintain the flow of
space-time so maybe by destroying those
stones Thanos caused chaos to spill
through the multiverse let me know which
of the snaps you think caused this in
the comments and let's move on
[Music]
so fury hill and beck are tracking and
containing these elemental monsters
which could be based on the elementals
from the Doctor Strange comics but as I
pointed out in past trailers there have
been Easter egg numbers on boats and
license plates linking them to issues of
spider-man comics that introduced
hydro-man Sandman and molten man
whichever these things are I think
there's a good chance that they're being
puppeted by Mysterio spider-man pitches
Thor and Captain Marvel as better hero
options this actually might be the first
time the name Captain Marvel has been
spoken out loud in the MCU since you
know secret identities are less of a
thing in general in the MCU and people
are more likely to go as Carol Danvers
or Clint Barton or rabbit Nick Fury was
the one to inspire the name Captain
Marvel like the Motown Marvelettes so
maybe it's a title that he and Hill had
been using there's also a shot of Peters
new black stealth suit perhaps get into
him by Furion Hill and maybe part of
Beck's original goal to make spider-man
be less noticeable hero so that he can
stand out more and look more like the
flashy hero that I want you to pay
attention to moving on
[ __ ] please you've been to space
Peter I want to go back on my trip with
the girl who I really like you tell her
how I feel
MJ I am spider-man no of course not
I mean it's kind of obvious after fury
reminds us of Peters space flight and
Infinity Ward Mysterio's soars past the
shard of London toward Tower Bridge and
MJ IDs Peter as spider-man which should
be a pretty big deal but Peter keeps
introducing himself to everyone in the
MCU with his real name with Doctor
Strange and Infinity Ward I'm Peter by
the way Doctor Strange all your made-up
names um I'm spider-man then Andy
introduced himself as Peter to Carol
Danvers an endgame so when it comes to
discretion Peter's definitely not the
Batman I make up and growl variety move
on you're right you may not be ready but
this is my responsibility
saving the world requires sacrifice
sometimes people die
London's Tower Bridge is attacked by
this massive monster which before I
thought could be a cloudy air elemental
but examining that more closely it looks
like it's made up of fire and muddy
earth I think this could be an even
larger fusion of the other three
elements that we've seen the fire one
the sand one and the water one all
together then Beck says this is my
responsibility perhaps another clue that
he doesn't want Peters interference
because he wants to steal Iron Man's
legacy as the new hero
then Peter wears these sunglasses which
are these same exact ones that Tony
Stark wore in infinity war and an
endgame
they provide a heads-up display that
shows heat signatures x-ray vision
perhaps stark left these for Peter in
his will and Peter finally put them on
here now surprised who accidentally sees
stuff that he didn't expect to see like
maybe through someone's clothes or maybe
these sunglasses are revealing Beck and
the elementals to be part of a grand
illusion in hopes Peter might also be
seen a post-mortem projection recording
of Tony Stark similar to the recording
at the end of endgame some important
message that he left behind for the kid
like Iron Man may be gone but I would
just love if our TJ REE cameos as Stark
in these jour le recordings and future
Marvel films to keep alive his presence
and his humor on to the next clip I feel
like I'm putting my friends in danger
the world needs Next Iron Man you're
going to step up or not
okay back in a shot at the bar Peter
tells Beck the world needs the next
Ironman and then Peter appears in Starks
jet with a holo display projecting his
suits web-shooters over his arm Tony
Stark would use these similar holo
displays for his armor and happy Hogan
nods proud to see Peter Parker
metaphorically filling in Tony Starks
suit like this then there's a shot of
Mysterio hovering over twisted debris of
that carnival setting that we've seen
before but if you listen closely you can
hear some gunfire suggesting that Beck
is blocking bullets considering all of
his other confrontations have been with
elemental monsters here he might be
fighting police or Furion Hill's unit
Peter sees another public shrine for
Iron Man and the face of Tony Stark has
been drawn inside this helmet I'm a
little curious as to why the shrine was
set up in this location maybe there
already was some Iron Man graffiti there
so they just brought in some candles or
since far from home is set across Europe
this could be in Monaco where Iron Man
fought whiplash and a Spider Man in his
stealth suit fights that fire monster we
move on to the glass clip okay so happy
Hogan shows up to save these kids after
they run from Tower Bridge in London but
as jet explodes judging from their
surroundings this is right outside the
world-famous Tower of London which is
located adjacent to the Tower Bridge in
the city but I want to know what causes
this jet to explode I don't see any
attack from the thing that was attacking
Tower Bridge or any projectile trail
from anything fired upon it a parked jet
especially one designed by Tony Stark
doesn't just go boom
maybe those can into the Tower of London
still work and some Beefeater was like
you can't pop that here let me know what
you think is going on here and how bad
my accent is and do you think Quentin
Beck is lying about the multiverse in
general or it's a multiverse real and
Becca's just lying about being from
another dimension comment down below
with your thoughts follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at ei vas and
subscribe to new rock stars on YouTube
and make sure to follow our new podcast
feeds inside Marvel for early access to
all of our Marvel breakdowns and
theories
oh hey Nick Fury's Colin's all answer
and am I talking to him it's here he's
awesome hello spider-man oh hey Nick
Louie what happened last time you
trusted someone I lost